diop salut à tous aujourd'hui on va
parler d'un sujet hyper important
comment perdre son ventre c'est un sujet
qui peut faire marrer certaines
personnes mais en réalité ça touche tout
le monde et surtout les hommes parce
qu'en réalité on est tous égaux face à
ça arrivé un moment autour de la
trentaine on commence tous apprendre du
bide alors pas parce qu'on fait les
dingues mais juste parce que notre
physiologie change du coup on voit
l'apparition bourrelets l'apparition de
ventre et que ça ça va être augmentée
par de consommation et par notre hygiène
de vie notre mode de vie
donc je vous fais quelques tuyaux que je
vais essayé de m'appliquer à moi même du
moins essayer d'équilibrer un petit peu
les choses parce que l'idée si vous vous
laissez pas se retrouver avec un corps
de body fitness parce que j'en suis
d'une absolument pas capable de gens
n'est absolument pas envie mais par
contre on va essayer de franchement
perte subite d'une façon relativement
simple parce qu'en réalité il suffit
juste d'avoir une bonne hygiène de vie
donc la première chose justement en
termes d'hygiène de vie ça va être
l'alimentation
il faut faire super gaffe à son
alimentation c'est super simple c'est de
faire un petit schéma qui va voir
regarde une valence avec up avec d'un
côté tout ce que tu va bouffer de gras
et qui très mauvais pour toi alors ça va
être des frites des burgers avec le
grignotage avec tout ce que tu veux
c'est pas forcément ça et de l'autre
côté il va ya voir l'activité physique
une fille tu vaux je veux en venir là
c'est les dépenses énergétiques en
classe avec le sport et d'une manière
plus générale savait toutes les
activités qui va pouvoir faire ok jusque
là rien de bien compliqué et là il va y
avoir la balance avec les réserves alors
les réserves c'est d'un côté le stockage
et d'un côté la perte de poids c'est à
dire l'augmentation des réserves et la
perte des réserves donc ça c'est le
stockage est hamas graisseuse en réalité
si tu veux donc ça veut dire que quand
tu va bouffer des frites des burgers et
que ça ça va augmenter quand on est plus
dans la balance à la pesée loup tabac
lance va diminuer la et du coup tu es
réserves ont augmenté parce que ça va
pencher par l'article donc là ce que tu
fais c'est
by stockage a contrario si tu augmentes
les activités que tu fais plus de sport
mais que justement tu fais gaffe et tu
diminues ici la balance elle va aller
par là et tu vas aller sur la perte de
poids
voilà mon lapin tu vois sur le principe
c'est ça parce qu'en réalité tout ça
c'est un équilibre
ça veut dire que si tu fais du sport
d'un côté garçons sur le sport mais
notre côté puis grignote de la merde et
tu bouffes de la merde et ben tu vas pas
perdre du poids pas pour autant tu dois
équilibrée des entrées étaient sorties
des entrées c'est ce que tu vas manger
donc les entrées dans ton corps dans
toute l'alimentation tu vas voir tout en
sachant que tout n'a pas le même apporte
tout ce qui va être sucré ça des entrées
qui vont être beaucoup plus outré
stocker beaucoup plus a contrario les
protéines tu vas beaucoup moins les
stocker et les sorties
c'est le sport les dépenses les dépenses
énergétiques que tu vas à voir donc si
tu rentres énormément avec deux côtes et
à des dépenses qui sont quand même
conséquente mais qui sont pas
suffisantes tu rentres beaucoup trop et
battus va quand même avoir trop évident
et ça malgré tout il faut le savoir
donc ça sert à rien de dire que je fais
du sport je n'écris pas be nice mais à
côté de ça je bouffe comme un dingue ça
ne marche pas il faut avoir une vie
saine et équilibrée
tu me suis ça veut dire que ça le miel
ça un très bon salle à aaa le sucre ça
ça c'est le diable ça ça c'est le diable
ça dégage les petites madeleines ça ça
ça dégage en réalité ce qu'il faut c'est
ça ça c'est très très très bon pour ce
que tu as à la carotte génial et en plus
ça c'est bon la carotte après tout
l'europe elles font mes légumes les
courgettes génial et qu'on jette alors
il n'y a pas de façon de pigier
d'ailleurs ce que je veux faire plaisir
qu'ils parlent de quelques petites
recettes qui sont super facile à faire
sont un peu direct 8 mètres la playlist
là d'ici quelques temps nul n'est fait
je te mets la playlist ont totalisé pas
les jeunes vont arrière comme un con
mais ce n'est que la playlist et sert
après des recettes faciles à faire qui
font pas grossir qui sont bonnes mais
qui est surprenante monde alors que tu
alimentation n'y a pas que ça il ya deux
choses sur lequel il faut faire
attention par exemple faut faire
attention à sa fiancée de la bière parce
que la bière si tu veux ça fait grossir
c'est hyper calorique la bière alors il
faut pas en voir ou alors en bois avec
modération
l'alcool était façon cela consomme avec
c'est très bon donc les bières à
proscrire autre chose qui n'est pas très
bon c'est ça le rhum c'est très bon
l'europe mais
c'est une très mauvaise idée parce qu'en
réalité si tu veux le rhum c'est pareil
comme tous les alcools hyper caloriques
et ça fait grossir alors c'est compliqué
ce soir le tai chi minh donc c'est très
bon
j'adore ça bon par contre au lieu de
boire du rhum qui mordille roth capuche
et a compris le principe les sucres soit
dégage mais elle colle avec modération
le mans rouge pareil avec modération ça
fait très grosse normalement grossière
tu manges des 40 ça c'est cool ça c'est
tout ce que tu fais rentrer dans ton
corps donc il faut vraiment faire entrer
des choses qui vont pas être trop
caloriques sinon tu vas prendre du point
maintenant on va attaquer la partie
exercice a besoin d'un exercice en face
aujourd'hui on a un rythme peu soutenu
l'exercice on le sait malgré nous mais
c'est quand même pas mal de prendre un
peu de temps chez soi y en a beaucoup
qui vont s'accorder pour faire un peu de
la muscu ou du cardio si vous avez le
temps tant mieux moi c'est pas mon truc
à la maison je pense qu'au quotidien
c'est hyper important de faire du sport
pas longtemps parce que sinon ça devient
chiant là tous des choses à faire neuf
gros activités on a souvent des journées
un peu compliqué mais ce qui peut être
hyper intéressant si vous dire voilà je
le prends dix 10 minutes 5 5 minutes
même pour ce faire une série de pompes
faire un peu de gainage quelques âmes
dossier ça et vous allez voir que au
quotidien ça va vous apporter des
dépenses supplémentaires
et ça va venir effectivement vous aider
dans votre perte de poids c'est ça qui
est important à d'autres c'est à dire
équilibrer la balance d entrée correcte
qui correspondent à ce que vous dépensez
de l'autre côté
alors maintenant la troisième partie
pour moi la plus importante
c'est la motivation c'est bien beau de
se dire j'aimerais bien perdre ce ventre
j'aimerais bien ne plus avoir ce petit
ventre et être gaulé comme un prince ou
comme une déesse
mais si en réalité en face de ça t'as
pas une volonté de faire tu te dis pas
tous les jours à l'essai pour moi
aujourd'hui c'est mon jour
et aujourd'hui je perds ce qui me guide
qui arrivera pas c'est clair la
motivation avant tout il faut y croire
peut être en accord avec soi même parce
que en réalité ce dont on parle
aujourd'hui c'est pas de se dire pendant
quinze jours trois semaines un mois je
fais attention à ce que je fais je mange
moins je fais plus de sport super mobile
ça sert à rien parce que tu vas perdre
tout va le reprendre et mais beaucoup
plus derrière
soit on parle aujourd'hui c'est de se
réinventer globalement c'est à dire
d'avoir eu notre hygiène de vie et de
rééquilibrer sa vie jaurès autres un peu
gourou quand je parle comme ça mais
c'est la réalité il faut partir du
constat que quand tu vieillis peu plus
de permettre tous les excès ou encore te
pardonne pas tu va stocker davantage tu
vas voir de la masse graisseuse chez les
mecs c'est dans le ventre et chez les
femmes c'est dans le cul en règle
générale il y en a un peu partout mais
c'est vraiment les endroits où l'on
stocke davantage
donc si tu apprends à bout de te
retrouver à 40 ans voire beaucoup plus
avec un bide énorme et un cul d'enfer il
va falloir s'y mettre dès aujourd'hui et
pas seulement pour une petite cure de
jouvence mais vraiment pour changer ton
style de vie durablement donc la
motivation c'est primordial pas pour se
dire allez je perds ce but comme ça je
rigolais l'été je fais le bim beau ou
gelée playboy sur la plage non ça sert à
rien c'est de se dire je change de style
de vie pour être en accord avec moi-même
pour avoir trouvé bien dans ma peau
si tu trouve bien dans ta peau avec des
petits qui ment plus gardien ça pose
aucun problème
il n'y a pas de diktat qui dit qu'il
faut être musclé aussi ça d'ailleurs je
parle même pas des risques et je parle
juste d'être bien dans son corps ok donc
là aujourd'hui je parle je parle de
l'autre parce que souvent c'est un
complexe sa complexe et les femmes
souvent très compliqué après une
grossesse et c'est un complexe chez les
mecs aussi même si normalement mais que
l'on met malgré tout voilà donc si t'as
pas une motivation ce n'est pas une
volonté de fer c'est pas la peine
d'essayer
une fois qu'ils seront d'accord peux te
retrouver vraiment la motivation ce qui
te donne envie d'aller dans cette
direction là tu pourras trimestre tu
pourras faire attention
ceci étant dit tu peux manger des
carottes monstre abouti ça reste un très
bon savait pas comment tu les cuisines
il ya un quatrième point
le quatrième procès de faire attention à
la tension à l' escalade
parce que en réalité au début sur des
dizaines de vies qui est pas bonne
tron va avoir tendance à prendre un peu
de bide plupart va passer plus notre
corps va stocker pour des dépenses
énergétiques ou pour d apport équivalent
en gros tu vas y dis dieu plutôt un gros
cul que tu seras vieux plutôt un gros
bide plus tu vieillis et plus il faut
faire d'effort pour avoir un physique
dans lequel on est bien si on a un
physique je dirais mens tu vois je masse
à 20 ans c'est facile
en règle générale pour la généralité à
20 ans c'est facile parce que notre
corps stocke très peu et plus tu
vieillis plus tu vas stocker donc à 20
ans izzy à 60 ans il faut vraiment
mettre les bouchées doubles donc quand
tu vois un mec de 60 ans qui est hyper
gaulle et dit wade est le mec il y en a
chié et qu'il a vraiment sué pour en
arriver là plus tu vieillis plus fort
envoyé du steak et alors il ya un autre
point qui est très important c'est qu'il
faut se dire que aujourd'hui quand on
commence à avoir un petit peu de bide
broncy c'est pas grave j'ai un peu de
bide c'est mignon derrière et des nanas
qui le diront moi j'adore les mecs avec
du vide oui ça c'est vrai attention
parce que plus tu vas prendre du ventre
petit va vieillir puis ce sera dur à
perdre déjà plus ça sera du rappeur déjà
physiquement psychologiquement parce
qu'il faut réussir dans sa tête à se
dire bon maintenant je change vraiment
ma façon de fonctionner sauf que quand
tu fonctionnes certaine manière depuis
des années c'est extrêmement compliqué
d'autant plus qu'il ya des vrais effets
pervers et sage de clément trail tu vas
voir c'est à dire que quand tu prends du
vide et que tu vieillis
il ya tous les phénomènes de
discrimination munitions de la qualité
de vie de la dépression parce que
souvent dépend d'un accord avec soi-même
et alors après quand tu es vraiment très
très gros il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'autres maladies et pathologies
cardiovasculaires forcément taille reste
à ce poste sur des artères et puis
forcément c'est le bordel tu as du gras
partout du diabète de l'arthrose
bon ben voilà ça c'est pour le côté
hyper négatif aujourd'hui on parle du
début du début du début on parle de
faire son petit ventre
une fois que tu as perdu ton petit
ventre dis toi bien que ça va t'aider
fort tout le reste parce que ça va très
des attraits inventé globalement à
trouver une nouvelle façon de voir les
choses et ça va t'aider dans ta vie de
tous les jours
déjà ça va aider au niveau de pont
physique après ça va t'aider au niveau
de temps tu as quand on est mieux dans
son corps on n'est plus dans sa tête on
est plus productif et anton couple site
en couple bien sûr tu seras mieux on
couple ça sentira mieux qu'il sera mieux
ouvert à t'accompagner watts son
compagnon par contre les toits bien truc
tu deviens gaulle et celle de l'est il
se peut aussi que ça à [ __ ] la merde
dans ton couple qui les opportunités
qu'ils créent que ce soit compliqué donc
il faut vraiment être en phase avec ce
même pas donc ce que tu vas créer
aujourd'hui ça va être globale pour un
bien-être de demain penserait ce que je
t'ai dit réfléchir à la motivation et
une facteur d'accord avec toi même à
l'attack est une paire se vide ok